Elon Musk is now worth $167 billion
dollars. And depending on when you’re
watching this video, he could be worth even more.
Despite all the five star
hotels he could sleep in,
the Tesla CEO chooses to sleep at his
factories. Not just now and again, but often.
That’s what he did during his recent visit to the
Gigafactory under construction in Berlin
- Tesla’s first vehicle factory in Europe
that will start turning out Model Ys this year.
Where do you sleep tonight?
Tonight, it’s in the factory.
In the factory? Not in a hotel?
Well, technically, a conference
room in the factory, but yeah.
You sleep in the conference room in
the not finished factory tonight?
Yah, it gives me a good feel for what’s going on.
Alone or...?
Yah, I assume so.
Is this an invitation? (Laughter)
Kidding aside, he’s been doing this for years.
Including camping on the roof of Tesla’s
battery factory in the Nevada desert.
And he showed CBS exactly
where he slept at Tesla’s
manufacturing plant in Fremont, California.
I sleep on the couch over there. Last time I was
here I actually slept literally on the
floor because the couch was too narrow.
When things get really intense and I don’t have
time to go home and shower and
change, so I just sleep here.
Saving time isn’t the only reason he
sleeps at work, it’s just his style.
He explains that he doesn’t want to be
one of those CEOs in an ivory tower,
far removed from the hardships his
employees face on the frontline.
He says he wants his pain to be worse than theirs.
There’s no question, his employees have had to
endure a lot to get Tesla to where it is today.
The company delivered nearly half
a million cars in 2020 - a stunning
achievement considering how close it
was to bankruptcy a few short years ago
as it struggled to mass-produce the Model 3.
In 2018, Tesla planned on
producing 5,000 Model 3s every week
but only managed about 800 a week in
the first three months of that year.
Frankly, we’re gonna be in
production hell. Welcome, welcome.
Part of the problem was that Tesla
relied on too much automation,
or, too many robots, too early. And any issue
would cause the entire assembly line to stop.
The human staff was also overworked, exhausted,
and according to a report in the Guardian,
even passing out on the factory floor.
In response to this article,
Musk said he cared deeply about the
health and safety of his employees
and emphasized that Tesla’s safety record
had improved significantly since then.
But shortly after, Tesla was hit by another
claim of high injury rates at the factory.
So Musk responded with an all-staff email
that’s been applauded by leadership experts.
He wrote: No words can express how much
I care about your safety and wellbeing.
It breaks my heart when someone is injured
building cars and trying their
best to make Tesla successful.
He went on to say he’d meet with every
injured employee and would "...go down
to the production line and perform
the same task that they perform.”
It’s not certain whether he actually
met with every single injured person
but this hands-on approach was clear evidence
that he’s willing to put himself at
the very heart of problem-solving.
And sleeping in his factories could go a
long way toward inspiring his employees
to make Tesla an overwhelming success
by helping the world transition
to sustainable energy.
Tesla aims to produce 20 million cars a year by
2030 - that’s 40 times what it produced in 2020.
Only an insane amount of hard
work will get Tesla there.
Musk says at times he’s clocked in more than 120
hours a week - a work ethic
that he adopted early on.
When he and his brother Kimbal
founded their first company,
Zip2, which was like an internet version of
the yellow pages, they only had one computer.
So the website ran during the
day while they coded at night.
They also slept at the office because they didn’t
have an apartment and showered at the YMCA.
He doesn’t expect his employees
to camp out at work but does
expect them to spend a lot of waking hours there.
During that painful production ramp-up of the
Model 3, staff was working 100 hours a week.
That’s the equivalent of 14
hours a day, seven days a week.
Critics say he pushed his workers
to the brink. Musk said there was
no other way to meet Tesla’s production targets.
The company bounced back and exceeded its
delivery goals in the second half of 2019.
Tesla is now the most valuable car company in
the world as its stock price continues to soar.
Musk’s rocket company SpaceX is
also soaring - literally - as
it tests out prototypes of
the massive Starship system
that plans to send people to the moon and Mars.
Even though his companies’ futures look
bright, the CEO says it’s no time to slow down.
He once explained that if someone is working
50 hours a week and you’re working 100,
you’ll get twice as much done in the course
of a year and be that much further ahead.
Perhaps this mentality is the
reason that on Glassdoor reviews,
only 65% of Tesla employees recommend working
there compared with 85% who recommend Apple.
That doesn’t mean people don’t
want to be hired at Tesla.
They just recognize it’s
a demanding place to work.
As Musk himself has admitted, “There
are way easier places to work,
but nobody ever changed the
world on 40 hours a week”.
So his couch-sleeping will
probably continue. Though
he might find it somewhat more comfortable now.
A YouTuber named Ben Sullins started
a GoFundMe to get Musk a bigger couch.
A furniture company caught wind
of it and offered one up for free.
The money raised ended up going to charity.
So, when do you think Tesla will be
able to produce 20 million cars a year?
Do you think it'll happen by
2030? Earlier? Later? Let me know.
And if you like what you saw,
as always, give it a like
and don't forget to subscribe to my channel.
And thank you very much to
my Patrons for your support.
I'm Cindy Pom and I'll see you next time.